from 8 news now
a new appreciation for the holidays we
meet a local family
who have a new outlook on christmas
after getting hit hard by covet 19.
plus relief is still in limbo an update
on the stalled bill to send money to
americans
struggling through the pandemic and
tracking your santa on christmas eve
plus
looking at what your christmas day how
about shaping up forecast in a few
minutes
now live this is 8 news now
live at 11. merry christmas eve everyone
thanks so much for joining us tonight at
11
i'm bianca holman families across the
valley are finding
new ways to celebrate the holiday in
light of the coronavirus
including those directly impacted by it
oracle mana shares the story of one
family
and they describe this as one christmas
miracle
christmas is always a time to spend with
family but amid covid19
loved ones are holding each other a
little tighter this year
one valley family tells me after
battling the virus
they're just grateful they can celebrate
the holiday we try to
enjoy every moment because as is
hard for a lot of people martine
palomino is counting his blessings this
christmas
martine his wife irene and their two
kids are now fully recovered after they
all tested positive for covid19 about a
month ago
i feel like kind of like a fever say
and my body start to be you know like
achy body
like you know chills irene tells me
things turned around
just in time for the holidays but there
are some lingering effects
i still having a little coffee once in a
while but i think it's part of that
i'm not contagious anymore we are
healthy right now like many hispanic
families in las vegas
christmas is extremely important to
martine and irene they've decked their
halls making them merry and bright
they're even cooking up a christmas
turkey with classic peruvian spices
and although this year isn't the large
celebration it usually is they're just
happy they can enjoy this holiday
together
we're really blessing and thankful to
them it's a christmas miracle
and as our community continues to combat
the coronavirus
they have a message for all of us
keeping us strong keep positive
help each other martine also wants to
encourage everyone to keep practicing
the basics
hand washing mask wearing and social
distancing
reporting in las vegas orca mana 8 news
now
new tonight the u.s is now requiring air
travelers from the u.k
to have a negative covet test before
coming here this comes as a new strand
of the virus
causes a spike in cases overseas
here at home nevada is reporting 45 more
new deaths
since wednesday cases are up more than 2
200.
here in the valley 30 more people have
died cases are up more than
1800 hospitalizations are down statewide
but the two-week positivity rate is up
slightly
to nearly 20 percent and a reminder
covet testing site hours
are changing this week because of the
holiday all the sites run by the county
will be closed tomorrow
then on saturday the site at texas
station will reopen
and we have a list of all the locations
as well as their hours on our website
at 8 news now dot com
and new at 11 dav rose anthony will not
get a new election in the race for
county commission district c
court records show his petition was
denied by a judge
anthony lost a close race to ross miller
the winner was decided by just
15 votes pretty close there
and it's now for a time to check of the
weather with ashley conway who's in the
accurate wow weather center hey there
bianca yeah we
had cloudy skies today all day today was
also chilly
and those clouds are continuing
overnight so santa as he makes his way
through here
he's going to have to break through
those clouds we'll take a look at santa
here in a second let's look at our
current conditions it's 42
outside we're seeing very light breezes
coming from the southwest at four miles
per hour we're actually four degrees
warmer
than we were this time yesterday but
we're still chilly outside
so tomorrow your christmas morning
waking up opening up presents 45 degrees
we're warming up
into those mid 50s tomorrow possibly
getting up into those
upper 50s maybe even 60 degrees
depending on where you live but right
now we're forecasting a high of 59
degrees for your christmas morning so
let's take a quick look
at that norad tracker and see where
santa is let's see he has delivered 6.6
billion gifts and he's in crane brook
canada they're in british columbia so
over on the western side
of canada hey so at least he's on the
west coast right bianca so he's making
his way slowly
yeah he's almost here huh back to you
all right looks like there won't be much
snow on mount
charleston for the holidays those
wanting a white christmas but there are
things to remember before heading up
if you're checking out lee canyon
bypasses online
along with a parking reservation you'll
need to wear a mask at all times once
you're up there
and as far as the rest of the mountain
pay attention to where you park or you
could get fined
and towed also keep your pets on a leash
and of course clean up after them
finally make sure trash ends up in the
dumpsters
or just take it with you when you leave
we gotta respect mother nature
now the next coveted relief package is
still in limbo tonight
this week the president said he would
not sign it into law
however cbs news reports the legislation
is being brought to him in
florida where he's spending the
christmas holiday paula reid has more on
what's next
house republicans turn back a push by
democrats to increase stimulus checks
from 600
to 2 thousand dollars the house stands
adjourned
it was a rebuke i'm asking congress to
amend this bill
after the president threatened to veto
the relief bill unless payments were
raised
with millions of americans in limbo
democrats are pushing him
believe it or not democrats agree
with the president at least to the
extent that we need to sign this bill
now
even republicans remain in the dark as
to the president's next move
the best way out of this to sign the
bill and i still hope that's what he
decides
the president was seen pulling into his
palm beach golf club today but otherwise
laid low after unleashing fresh
controversy last night when he announced
a slew of new clemency actions
including a full pardon for his
son-in-law jared kushner's father
charles kushner who had pleaded guilty
and was sentenced to two years in jail
for preparing false tax returns and
witness retaliation
including using a prostitute to
blackmail his brother-in-law a witness
in the case
that case was prosecuted in the early
2000's by trump ally chris christie
it's one of the most loathsome
disgusting crimes
that i prosecuted when i was u.s
attorney mr trump also extended pardons
to his former advisors roger stone
and paul manafort both convicted on
charges stemming from the special
counsel investigation into russian
meddling
of the more than 80 clemency actions the
president has issued while in office
58 were for people he knows personally
were done as a favor to an associate
or were granted for political benefit
but the president's choices were met
with criticism
even from republicans like ben sasse who
called the moves
rotten to the core once the stimulus
bill is physically here in florida the
president is able to sign it quickly if
he wants to
but even with millions of americans in
limbo the white house still refuses to
say what the president will do
paula reid to cbs news west palm beach
florida
in a tweet tonight nevada representative
suzy lee says the house will vote for
two thousand dollar payments on monday
she's calling on everyone to step up and
help struggling americans with checks
and extended unemployment benefits
right now federal unemployment benefits
are set to expire this weekend
unless that bill is signed the state
employment department says
hundreds of nevadans will lose out on
money dieter officials say they were
fully prepared to implement the relief
bill
but now their hands are tied the
department says it's now
virtually impossible to avoid a gap in
benefits for nevadans
this isn't the only item being held up
help with emergency food assistance
emergency rental assistance another
round of small business
grants and loans emergency
efforts to stop people from becoming
homeless
all are being held up while we as
nevadans are trying as hard as we can
to prevent devastating outcomes for
families
anyone receiving benefits from nevada
can still
file weekly claims those applying for
the pua program will eventually get
caught up on payments
after the delay the latest unemployment
report from the department shows a
slight drop this
week initial claims are down by more
than 11 percent compared to early
december
however continued claims increased by
nearly 1600
the pua program saw a 70 percent drop in
claims
and a heads up for anyone traveling
through mccarran airport tonight and
tomorrow many of the concessions will
have shorter hours because of the
holiday
the airport urges travelers to pack some
extra snacks before you leave
just in case and some good news this
christmas eve
we've gotten tons of calls about this
our parent company next our media group
has reached an agreement with
dish network that means all the
companies 164 local tv stations have
been restored
to the carrier's lineup including 8 news
now the deal also means next star's
cable network
wgn america will be added to sling tv
early next year and still ahead the
night before christmas will be one to
remember for one local
gambler plus it's the season of giving
and
one woman is going above and beyond to
make a difference for those
who need it including folks right here
in las vegas
but first a quick check of sansa and his
reindeer you know
rudolph his reading the pack he's all
done on the east coast and midwest
and guess what he's headed to utah right
now so far he's delivered
more than six billion gifts
at sahara
you're watching 8 news now live at 11.
a quick shout out to a big winner on
christmas eve
kevin hit a mega bucks progressive
jackpot
at the suncoast casino take a look at
that big check
pretty fat there more than 15 million
dollars
thanks to the suncoast for sharing this
photo on twitter
and in the season of giving we're
learning something about the ex-wife of
amazon's ceo
mckenzie scott's divorce made her one of
the richest women in the world
now as michael george explains we know
that she's also
one of the most generous
at the borough of manhattan community
college the news came quietly
with no fanfare or publicity quite
honestly i thought it was a prank i
thought it was okay maybe it's a you
know 50
maybe 75 maybe 100 000 donation
but when i was told that it was 30
million dollars i actually had a moment
i began to cry
there were similar reactions around the
country as mackenzie scott gave away
more than
4 billion dollars to 384
organizations the ex-wife of amazon's
ceo jeff bezos said in a blog post
she wanted to relieve both immediate
suffering and long-term systemic
inequities
this year alone she's given away nearly
6 billion dollars
why do you think she chose bmcc
i think the data speaks for itself our
students are determined they're focused
they have
grit goodwill industries of michiana
provides education training and job
placement for its indiana community
the mission received 10 million dollars
to have somebody
who doesn't even know us but to be able
to take a look and see what we are doing
it's a validation 10 million also went
to united way in sacramento california
it's going to mean
that you know children are going to have
access to the tools they need to be
successful in the classroom
charitable giving has surged during the
pandemic
with many americans donating generously
to food banks and local
charities scott says she's far from
finished
at the borough of manhattan community
college students
made a video to thank her for the
donation thank you my kansas cut
saying the gift will change their lives
for years to come
michael george cbs news new york
united way of southern nevada is one of
the hundreds of organizations getting a
boost thanks to scott
the author and philanthropist donating
10 million dollars the largest gift
ever for the non-profit it was a
nonprofit's work during the pandemic
that helped them
stand out as far as how the money will
be used
leaders say they're working on a plan
that will possibly
impact the community the most wow that
is so
amazing so glad that she's doing that i
know our united way
organization here they help so many
people over the summertime with
you know their rent payments and all
that utilities and of course clothes and
food
so much it's been it's been a hard year
for a lot of people so when
organizations can step up and do that
it's really amazing to hear and see
so sure yeah well speaking of gifts
right
we have santa claus coming to town
before we get into our weather nice live
look there of the strip let's go ahead
and check out our norad tracker so we've
had
6.7 isn't that unbelievable we had 6.6
billy now we got 6.7 billion
back in mexico he was in british
columbia last time now he's in las
cruces mexico
new mexico i'm sorry about that so he is
in the united states um we'll see when
he comes here to las vegas but he's
going to have to break through
some clouds and of course you can't see
it in our view there but there's been
clouds all day today there will be those
clouds overnight
i'll talk more if we're going to see
sunny skies or clouds tomorrow morning
so our high today was 48 degrees we're
actually supposed to be in those low 50s
so we didn't even break out of our 40
degree
mark today so we are definitely you can
see almost 10 degrees
below our normal high for this time of
year
some of our temperatures around the
valley we're seeing 29 up at kyle canyon
frigid up there at least for us here
down in the valley we're seeing lots
of 40s everywhere 37 aliante we're also
seeing 38
in nellis air force base so those colder
30s over on the north side of town
and again mostly 40s throughout our
valley we're seeing lots of 40s and 30s
throughout our region we have 32
in kingman freezing there 39 in boulder
city 42 in mesquite
35 in pahrump and 52 degrees in laughlin
it's almost a 20 degree difference
from what we're seeing there in param
okay so we are going to have a sunny
christmas morning so that's good so as
you're waking up
to your presents opening up your
presents kids want to head outside and
play
we are going to have those sunny skies
for tomorrow but we have the
evening rain chances it looked almost
like it could rain today
and tonight but we're not going to see
any rain we're seeing rain in southern
california rather but we're going to see
some rain chances
making its way through here late sunday
night and going into monday morning as
well as monday afternoon
you can kind of see where that those
showers were here in california
kind of just dissipated didn't really
have a strong hold to make its way
it wasn't a strong enough system to make
its way here to las vegas so just lots
of clouds what we've seen today clouds
over our state
again we saw those nice nice
temperatures
today it was chilly and we're going to
see those sunny skies for tomorrow
and i want to take a look at this future
cast so we can kind of pinpoint where
we'll see not only the rain here going
into monday afternoon monday
early monday morning but also the snow
showers so we're going to definitely see
some snow
chances the higher probability of that
in the mountains
versus those rain chances what we're
looking at so let's take a look at what
our extended forecast is of course
it's christmas eve christmas morning is
tomorrow
we're going to see again those overnight
showers what we're looking at let's see
we get our
our graphic pulling up here it's kind of
sticking a little bit there we go bianca
monday showers and then we're looking at
mid 50s for the week back to you
a new clicker is on the christmas list
coming up in sports there's still
uncertainty on the waiter's roster
head coach john gruden says both
quarterbacks are still in practice
and a starter has yet to be picked
plus the full breakdown of the match-up
against miami
hear how the dolphins feel heading into
allegiant stadium
sports is next
silver state schools credit union
[Music]
eric practiced today practiced yesterday
so did mariota
we'll see what happens here tomorrow in
terms of
which way we go but we'll have two
quarterbacks prepared to play
that was head coach john gruden's update
earlier today on who we can expect for
the raiders home finale at allegiant
stadium
saturday against the dolphins obviously
still no definitive answer on whether it
be derrick carr
or marcus mariota carr still recovering
from that significant grain injury that
he suffered earlier in last thursday's
game against the chargers
in which he did not return with mariota
taking over the quarterbacking duties
in the 30-27 overtime loss now today
carr was a full participant
for second straight practice with both
him and mariota getting equal reps
at the end of the day coach struden says
they're going to do what's right and
what's best for carr and his health
i'm gonna let the cat out of the bag
here i'm gonna make sure he is okay
you know i'm gonna make sure that
physically he has a chance to wake up in
the morning and
go through his rehab one more day and do
all the things that he needs to do
against one of the top defenses that
blitzes almost every play
uh so we gotta do what's right mariota
you know is also uh performed well so
like i said uh we'll have a quarterback
under the center and
we're excited to play a really good
football team so we may not know who the
starter will be until game time on
saturday and
with more let's head out to the newsroom
with molly sullivan who has a preview
of this week's 16 matchup
welcome to week 16 in the national
football league let's crunch the numbers
shall we and get the record straight
here the las vegas raiders
have not been eliminated from a
postseason berth knocked down
losing for the last five but to say las
vegas is knocked out would be inaccurate
the raiders need to win out the season
to reach the playoffs for the first time
since 2016 the
miami dolphins and the baltimore ravens
must also lose out
dolphins head coach brian flores was
asked about his team's mindset
pretty standard question here but flores
replied
our playoff is this week against the
raiders the dolphins are coming off a
22-12 victory over the patriots which
mathematically eliminated new england
from the playoffs for the first time
since 2008.
meanwhile the dolphin secret secured a
winning season for the first time since
2016.
as for the raiders quarterback situation
derek carr suffered a groin injury late
in the first quarter of thursday night's
overtime loss to the los angeles
chargers
and did not return carr had only missed
two regular season games and one playoff
game
in seventh season he's a gamer and has
fought through injury before rookie
season with his knee and in 2017 with
his back
carr said he will do everything he can
to be on that field
the best part of my game is my mind carr
said and that's still working
now if carr can not play marcus mariota
will get the start
after coming off the bench thursday
night with a fresh legs and no
hesitation
he went 17 for 28 throwing 226 yards
and a touchdown mariota also picked up
88 yards on the ground the fourth most
by a quarterback in franchise history
and ran for another touchdown
that tied the score at 24 in the fourth
quarter
whoever's in the huddle there's a lot
riding on these final two games in terms
of the direction of the franchise
getting to nine and seven is everything
for the raiders right now it all comes
down to saturday night at alleged
stadium
molly sullivan 8 sports now all right
thank you molly that does it for sports
have a merry christmas
everybody and we'll be right back after
this break
from 8 news now
you're watching eight news now live at
11.
all right let's check back in on saint
nick tonight he and his team with
rudolph
leading the pack has made it to the west
coast now
he was last seen in cabo san lucas
headed towards
ensenada mexico santa typically makes it
here to vegas
just after midnight hopefully the kids
are asleep right now
we hope you keep sending us your photos
of your decorated homes to our facebook
page
we're continuing to showcase some of the
best in southern nevada take a look at
this
some pictures from the lefler family up
in this northwest part of the valley
every single year they decorate both
sides of their driveway and their garage
with santas bears
and nutcrackers looking good and be sure
to join eight news now
and sunny 106.5 as we bring you a very
sunny christmas
a benefit special for opportunity
village las vegas headliners are raising
money for their organization
join good day las vegas john langler and
alex
backus along with our friends at
sunny 106.5 for a very sunny christmas
it airs again
tomorrow christmas day at noon perfect
time as you open up gifts
and again at 6 30 p.m here on 8 news now
and that's all for us at 11 the late
show with stephen colbert is next
and as we say goodbye tonight we leave
you with a performance
of have yourself a merry little
christmas
happy holidays everyone
[Music]